So ChatGPT now has an additional functionality
called Scheduled Tasks.
This allows you to set up recurring work,
whether it be daily or weekly,
so that you can automate some of your day-to-day activities
using ChatGPT.
To utilise this feature, what you need to do
is go into the top left,
and then click on GPT-4o with Scheduled Tasks.
Could say, let's create a task every day
to make a social media post
for my data engineering consultancy.
I want to make a new post at 8am every day.
And then ChatGPT task is gonna realise
that this is a task that needs to be done.
So you can see it says, create a task,
and it's going to remind us every day at 8am.
If you click on the triple dots,
you can either pause the task, edit the task,
and you can see this is the name of the task.
The instructions tell me to make a social media post,
and we could also say,
we could change this to generate a social media post
for my data engineering consultancy.
You can change the schedule
to daily, weekly, monthly, annually, or custom.
And then as well as that,
the other thing you'll want to do to activate this
is make sure that you have desktop notifications turned on.
So remember to click allow there.
Your notifications are turned on.
Also, the other place you'll need to go
to see all of your tasks
is go on your profile icon in the top right,
click on that, go to tasks in beta,
and then you can see these are all the tasks
that you've got where you can pause or delete a task,
or you can edit a task as well there.